I'm lucky if I get only five seconds  I just little button time it's about the  silence  I'm gift.you standard no real home no  parents no school surrounded by hate  broke in on the hustle but with feet  difference is I choose to see my world  differently my screwed-up world  positively well I try it least  imagine you could dance to the sound of  your fears is there of noise tears the  chaos disappears poverty someday that  scene is a disability but to me I look  at this concrete jungle society and  think surely I'm the one that's free  you will never hear the silence without  the noise would I want to be doing  something else  never this is my life and I'm pretty  sure I'll keep dancing forever